الصين تسير حسب مبدأ النصر دون
قتال. وهذا ما يخيف الولايات
والتطور في الصناعات الصينية.
وفي كسب الاسواق العربية كذلك.
باردة بين المحور الصيني الروسي
من جهة وامريكا والناتو من الجهة
العيون الضيقة. فهل تستغل بكين
هذا تدور في الوقت الحاضر حرب
تعاظم نفوذ الصين جعلها تترك
الفراغ في الشرق الاوسط لاصحاب
حياة. لذلك يخاف الامريكيون.
العرب وفي مقدمتهم الجزائر ومصر
الشرق الاوسط فرصة للصين وروسيا
لملء الفراغ. ولكن خوف امريكا من
الامريكان مواجهة تمدد التنين
الصيني بالمنطقة والعالم فضلا عن
من دول الشرق الاوسط فلماذا كل
هذه الانسحابات بعد ان شهدت
الولايات المتحدة ان تواجدها في
المنطقة العربية وحربها على ما
والاسبانية واليابانية عام رافق
كل ذلك من قيادة لدول اوروبية
تسميه بالارهاب اصبحا يسببان
ضررا اكبر عليها اقتصاديا
وهو ما يجعل لعاب القادة
الامريكيين يسيل للاستحواذ على
غنيمة كهذه عقب بايدن الرئاسة
رجب جنرال فرانك ماكنزي قائد
السوق العربية في مجال التسليح.
ومن ذلك يقلق الامريكان من خسارة
تركة اربع امبراطوريات استعمارية
كبرى البريطانية والفرنسية
ناتج قومي اجمالي في العالم.
ولانها خرجت منتصرة بعد الحرب
سنويا ولكن هذه المليارات ستنقص
من الميزانية الامريكية هنا يجن
الامريكان? يقولها الخليجيون لكن
الاعذار كثيرة جدا وما من سبب
العرب عموما وليس السعودية فقط
اميركا التي صارت قائدة العالم
واشنطن الاسلحة التي تريد وتمنع
عنهم بقية الاسلحة. لماذا ايها
ايضا حينها فهل على الولايات
المتحدة الامريكية ان تخاف خسارة
اسواق للاسلحة قد ترفد ميزانيتها
الاقتصادية بمليارات الدولارات
واسيوية اخرى كالمانيا وايطاليا
او تركيا وباكستان والمكسيك
المتحدة اكثر. فكيف لهم ان
يواجهوا هذا التنامي المتسارعة
وقد تساعدهم في صناعة الاسلحة
النووية وهذا ما تخشاه واشنطن
بعد زاحتها بريطانيا بعد الحرب
العالمية الاولى كصاحبة اكبر
ايران سلاحا نوويا فالسعودية
ستعلن عن امتلاك السلاح النووي
تبيع الصين الصواريخ بانواعها
للسعودية. ويخاف الامريكان ان
تتجرأ السعودية اكثر وتستورد
اسلحة نووية من بكين. لكن هذا لن
حقا وهو ما صرحت به المملكة
مخاطبة امريكا ان لو امتلكت
العالمية الثانية دون الدمار
الذي الحقته المانيا وروسيا
وبريطانيا ببعضهم بعضا. امريكا
ورثت العالم كليا او جزئيا من
يحدث بحسب التقارير الامريكية.
فالصين تساعد في صناعة الاسلحة
وبسعر اقل. وهنا تخشى واشنطن
خسارة سوق القاهرة. الدول
استيراد الاسلحة الامريكية. لكن
الصين تعطي اسلحة بنفس المواصفات
اسواق الاسلحة. قبل اكثر من ثلاث
سنوات تعددت زيارات مسؤولي
والافريقية وواشنطن تعلم ان سوق
الجزائر للاسلحة سيدر عليهم
الامريكان ارادوا ان يخطبوا
الجزائريين وبدت هذه الرغبة
يتحدث واي نقلة نوعية التي
احدثها اصحاب العيون الضيقة. ما
وسياسيا. الهذا خافت امريكا حقا?
لا ليس ذلك وحسب. بل يريد
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية الى
الجزائر وكانت اخرها زيارة وزير
عبدالمجيد تبون ورئيس اركان
الجيش الفريق السعيد شنقريحة.
مقنع. وهنا يتجه الخليجيون
تلقائيا تجاه الصين. وهكذا تكسب
هذه السوق السخية التي تغدقهم
بالاموال. فهل لهم ان يتركوا
كانت قبل عشرة اعوام تعتمد على
استيراد الاسلحة تحتل اليوم
العالم. ولهذا يخاف الامريكان ان
يخسر حلفاءهم العرب. الصين التي
لو امتنع العرب من شراء الاسلحة
الامريكية؟ هل الولايات المتحدة
والمغرب. بحسب مجلة فقد اشترت
الجزائر من موسكو اسلحة بقيمة
من بيع الاسلحة للدول العربية في
افريقيا وعلى رأسها الجزائر ومصر
الصيني. جمهورية مصر صاحبة اقوى
الجيوش العربية من ابرز اسواق
وتمتلك روسيا اسلحة تضاي اسلحة
الولايات المتحدة او قد تفوقها
والفين وثمانية عشر. وفي السنوات
الاخيرة اتجهت تركيا الى الاسلحة
مواجهة روسيا. لكن الصين تصعد
بسرعة الصاروخ في شتى مجالات
والسعودية والعراق والمغرب هم من
اكبر مستوردي الاسلحة في العالم
العرب لشراء اسلحتهم من الصين؟
ولماذا تخاف امريكا ان يرتاد
قوة لكن الساحة العالمية اليوم
قد دخلها لاعب اخر واي لاعب هذا
الروسية بعد رؤيتها لصعوبة شراء
الاسلحة التي تحتاجها من امريكا
الامريكي مليارات الدولارات من
صفقات بيع الاسلحة للعرب. فماذا
المركز الثاني على قائمة الدول
المنتجة للاسلحة عن اي تطور
الذي سينافس امريكا قائدة العالم
بالتأكيد لن يكون سوى التنين
الثانية. وهذه الحرب اكثر قلقا
وايذاء للامريكيين قبل ان تؤذي
امريكا من افغانستان في الوقت
الذي ينسحب فيه الامريكان ايضا
جنون امريكا فماذا هم فاعلون?
لماذا الخوف? بشكل مفاجئ انسحبت
وسواها وبعد هذا كله هل يسلم
الامريكان للصين الجمل بما حمل?
النفطية والغنية بالنفط والغاز
كالسعودية والامارات وقطر تبيعهم
ثلاثة عشر مليار وخمسمائة مليون
دولار ما بين عامي الفين وستة
على جيوب العرب. العرب غنيهم
وفقير يشترون اسلحتهم من واشنطن
القارة السمراء بكل ثقة حتى ان
الصين وروسيا سيطرتا على كبيرة
وتظل الجزائر من اكبر المستوردين
للاسلحة في الدول العربية
المصري على حق? نعم. فقلب امريكا
دائما مع اسرائيل وانما عينها
مليارات الدول فهل يتركنا?
بالتأكيد لا. لكن هل يقبل
الحرب الباردة الجديدة التي
اشتعلت تجاريا بين الولايات
الدفاع الامريكي الاسبق مارك
اسبر والذي التقى رئيس البلاد
فخرج بتصريح هناك بان عدم
الاستقرار في المنطقة تفاقمه
هي السوق الاوحد للسلاح؟ لا
بالطبع. لكن ايضا ماذا لو اتجه
القيادة المركزية الامريكية وقال
سيكون تقليص الوجود العسكري من
واضحة في تصريح الوزير الامريكي
بمواجهة النفوذ الصيني الروسي
الانشطة الخبيثة الصينية
والروسية في القارة الافريقية
المتحدة مع الصين بعد ان وضع
العملاق الاسيوي اقدامه في
الجزائريون بصفقات امريكية? هذه
القضية عويصة اكثر. فما العمل?
يقولها الامريكان. من الممكن
ادراج التحركات الامريكية ضمن
العرب سوق الاسلحة الصيني. لماذا
يفعل الامريكان كل ذلك? حرب
عبقريتكم ايها الامريكان هو انكم
ابدا لا تتخذوا خطوات غبية واضحة
كوننا نسينا شيئا. قالها جمال
عبدالناصر يوما. الم يكن الرئيس
فكيف لهم ان يهزموها باسلحتها؟
في المقابل يتلقى الاقتصاد
بل تقومون بتحركات غبية معقدة
مما يجعلنا نتساءل في امكانية